From now on Naka City for a little while On
the night when a shooting star swung by in the sky A
beautiful sparkling tooth fell on this star
This stone had a mysterious power that no one knows
Everyone in the world knows its secret  I started looking into it to find out,
but
many years have passed since then On
the night of a shooting star,
this time, a pitch-black stone fell from the darkness
Many scary monsters appeared from the black
stone
People, animals, flowers, and even trees  It
was destroyed in a mess It appeared when everyone was about to give up
thinking that everything would be destroyed at this rate
[music]
Sounds like we're
fighting with music I
'm sorry
I couldn't let you touch music
all this time But from now on I'll surely be able to listen to it I'll be able to stay in this town forever
I'm just going to look at a nearby market I
'm
thinking of having it where
Noah
goo
goodgood
this is called a
piano  If only I could get this much with the lights
I guess I've been waiting for a while
Yeah yeah
When the music comes
back4  Enter
[music] he's
lying
yeah yeah meme me car yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
me
public song thai
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
0 minutes
[music]
me
This is the
music
No
more sister
Please
don't worry about it Maestro
Sawahigashi.
You're still wasting my Irochi with your
inefficient fighting style,
and Mr. I told you to do
your best even when hunting a single rabbit.  It
's just that I can't control the output, right?
Actually, that point is really a direction for me too.
I really want to ask for adjustments,
why do
n't you just lend me a hand every so often?
Maestro
shuts up Tissue
I'm
sorry Everyone, please
go back to your daily life Kou z Let's go Yes, that onee-chan
gackt Hey, you really understand the current situation
New York is far away, but it's still a long
way off What will happen on the way?  I don't know if we
all have to act with a firm awareness, we can't
get
there.
You heard me I know you didn't hear me
Thinking with common sense, it was impossible to continue the video at the place just
before
Maestro  If you beat them all,
there shouldn't be a problem
.
But it's too bad
You can let this guy eat even a little sister who is too sweet
Only one little sister Dam
If you're a brother, you'll have Charlotte in New York
I don't know if you can take one sister and
sister
set  Talk
I need to pick up the pace a little more I want you to see 5 z as soon as possible
I need something sweet
Yeah yeah yeah
Street run
Why did you come here
Frankly speaking, it's the worst timing From
here to New York  This road is
the shortest route to the
city, isn't it?  came out
One day, more and more Yukinori will show up.
Samasa,
wow,
if you're going to avoid this road,
you'll have to go around in circles
.
But I think the action plan was
too naive.
This
maestro has already
finished replenishing his calories, so is it
okay if I follow your instructions earlier?
It's
possible You can secure a route to New York,
and you can fully enjoy the music of the
machines there.  Music takes precedence over anything It's nothing
to say when you can get through it
[Applause]
[Music]
Ca
n't you tell me about
it?  did voodoo
ano ah ah
[music]
Brother, are you okay?
Masha or Conductor and 6 o'clock
cart I
wonder if
you came to help
us after all.  It's completely different from the annihilation of 2, so it
's completely different, so you're in New York
, aren't
you?
It
's
really bad that Maeichiro is always
selfish
.
Music will save the world.
It's
big  Send me the Ora Cover edition and then speak
I did my best
The d2 guys in the tantrums kept attacking
me Did I hit it hard too?
Then all of a sudden, something huge called Khan
cowardly hid itself in the back row behind
me.
The
Maestro didn't have enough calories, so I thought he
should have at least rushed to the scene, so he was
confident that he could leave the company alone as a conductor,
so he rushed out If he bought too much, he'd be a
wreck at 6 o'clock cart
Come on up  Anyway, recklessness is prohibited, and assaults are also prohibited
Unless
you do something about it, you won't be able to listen to music around here.
I don't care what the reason
is.The point is, I try to make it so it can't stay
still and drag it out
.
I'll let
you know how many years it's been years It's been a while since
I heard that it was a live performance year
Kurt knocked Minoru down at 6 o'clock
Borrow
goo
Days hates sounds made by people
Especially beautiful music that is harmonious and rhythmic The more
exquisite the music, the more I can endure it It
's the beginning of a concert that looks like red
[music]
wh
me yeah yeah
yeah
Yeah
Black stone
I see I
've been drawn to this city by the graphite meteoric iron That's
why it
doesn't come out easily How
long have you been sleeping
?
[Music] After
that big country or after the meteorite?
[MUSIC]
Somehow I managed to break through the fullness
I want to carry on with this momentum to reach New York
Hey
, someone who looks like he's going to have a great day
today Why is it all about getting nourishment with
such skill and enthusiasm?
This time it worked out somehow,
but please cooperate so that we can continue navigating a little more
Where is about 1 there?
Listen
to me,
Chain Cater,
this calorie will give me new strength
Listen to me
[Applause]
I'm heading for town
[Music]
Come out
, sing Lauda
I've been thinking about it for a long time
[music]
Ghan ani
[music
] Princess who
passed over
[music]